[Applause]
all the members of parliament
ladies and gentlemen
i'm addressing all the people of the
united kingdom
and all the people
from the country with a big history
i'm addressing you as a citizen as a
president
of also a big country
with a dream
and big effort
i would like to tell you about the three
days of
about the 13 days of war
the war that we didn't start
and we didn't want it
however we have to conduct this war
we do not want to lose
what we have what is ours our country
ukraine
just the same way as you
once didn't want to lose your country
when nazis
started to
fight your country
and you had to fight for britain 13 days
of this struggle
on day one at four o'clock in the
morning we were attacked by cruise
missiles
everybody woke up
people children
the entire ukraine and since that we
have not been sleeping
we have all been fighting
for our country with our army
on day two
we have been fighting airstrikes
and our heroic
military servicemen on the islands
meaning they have been trying to fight
one russian
flag
when russian forces demanded that we lay
down the arms
however
we did continue fighting and
and we did we did feel
our force
the fourth of our people that
oppose their occupants until the end
the next day the aotearoa artillery
started fighting
on day four we started
getting people captive
we
have not been torturing them
we
remained humane
even on day four of this terrible war
on day five
the terror against us was
going on against children against cities
and
constant shelling have been taking place
around the country including hospitals
and that didn't break us
and that gave us feelings
of
that is the place where the nazis
killed
thousands of people during the second
world war
and 80 years after the russia
hit at them for the second time
and even
churches are getting destroyed
we have seen russian tanks hitting
the
atomic power station
um the result that we were looking for
yes we did feel that
we did fail
we did feel that unfortunately that the
alliances
don't work properly always
and the no-fly zone cannot be enforced
and on day 10 the
ukrainians started protesting
stopping the um
armored vehicles with their own hands
and on day 11.
the
children and cities were being hit and
hospitals as well with the rockets and
constant shelling
and
on that day we realized that europe
ukrainians became heroes
the
entire cities children adults
and on day 12
the
losses of
russian army exceeded 10 000.
and also including the general and that
gave us hope
that there will be some kind of
responsibility for those people
in front of the court on day 13
in the city of mariupol that was
attacked by the russian force a child
was killed
they do not allow any food and a water
and people started panicking
i think everybody
can hear that
people do not have water over there over
13 days of this
situation
over 50
children have been killed
these are the children that could have
lived
but these people have taken them away
from us
ukraine we're not looking to have this
form
the ukraine have not been looking to
become
big but they have become big over the
days
of this war
[Music]
the we are the country that are saving
people despite um
despite having to fight the one of the
biggest country one of the biggest
armies in the world
days this question
could have been asked
but now i can give you a definitive
answer it's definitely yes to be
and i would like to remind you the words
that the united kingdom have already
heard
which are important again
we will not
give up and we will not lose
but we will
fight till the end at sea
we will continue fighting for our land
whatever the cost
we will fight in the forests in the
fields
on the shores
in the streets
that we will fight
on the on the banks of different rivers
like nipper
and we
i'm very grateful to you boris
please increase the pressure of
sanctions
against this
country and please recognize this
country as a terrorist state
and please make sure that our ukrainian
skies are safe
please make sure
that well you do
what needs to be done
best of all to ukraine and
to the united kingdom